if we look at the cleanest formulation
of that
of looking at a problem from different
perspective
you're also involved with the
international mathematics olympiad
which takes a small clean
uh problems that are really hard but
once you look at them differently
can become easy but that little jump of
innovation is is uh is the entire trick
so maybe at the high level can you say
what is the international mathematical
olympiad
sure so this is uh the competition for
people who aren't yet in college
uh math competition which is the most
prestigious one in the entire world
it's the olympics of mathematics but
only for people who aren't yet in
college
now the kinds of questions that they ask
you to do are not computational
usually you're not supposed to find that
the answer is 42
right instead you're supposed to explain
why something is true
yes and the the problem is that at the
beginning when you look at each of the
questions
first of all you have four and a half
hours to solve three questions
and this is one day and then you have a
second day which is four and a half
hours
three questions but when you look at the
questions they're all asking you explain
why the following thing is true which
you've never seen before
and by the way even though there are six
questions if you solve any one of them
you're a genius and you get an honorable
mention so this is
this is hard to explain a hard problem
is it one person is it a team
ah so it's each country can send six
people
and the score of the country is actually
unofficial there's not an official
country versus country
system although everyone just adds up
the point scores of the six people and
they say well now which country
uh stacked up where yeah so maybe as a
side comment i should say that
um there's a bunch of countries
including the former soviet union and
russia
where i grew up where this is one of the
most important competitions that the
country participates in like
it was a source of pride for a lot of
the country
you you look at the olympic sports like
uh
wrestling weightlifting there's certain
sports
and hockey that russia
and the soviet union truly took pride in
and actually the
mathematical olympiad it was one of them
for many years
it's still one of them and that's kind
of fascinating we don't
think about it this way in the united
states maybe you can correct me if i'm
wrong but
it's not nearly as popular in the united
states in terms of its integration into
the culture
into uh just basic conversation into the
pride
like you know if you win an olympic gold
medal or if you win the super bowl
you can walk around proud i think that
was the case with the mathematical
olympiad in russia
not not as much the case in the united
states i think
so i just want to give that a little
aside because beating anybody
from russia from the eastern republic or
from china is very
very difficult there like if i remember
correctly
you know there's people this was a
multi-year
training process they train hard
and this is this is everything that
they're focused on
my uh my dad was was uh
was a participant in this and it's i
mean it's uh it's as serious as olympic
sports you think about like gymnastics
like young athletes participating
gymnastics
this is as serious as that if not more
serious so
i just want to give that a little bit of
context because we're talking about
serious high-level math
athletics almost here yeah and actually
i also think that it
made sense from the soviet union's
perspective because
if you look at what these people do
eventually
even though let's look at the ussrs or
the
international math olympiad record even
though they i say even though they won
a lot of awards at the high school thing
many of them went on to do incredible
things
in research mathematics or research
other things and
that's showing the generalization
generalizability
of what they were working on because
ultimately
we're just playing with ideas of how to
prove things
and if you get pretty good at inventing
creative ways to
turn problems apart split them apart
observe
neat ways to turn messy things into
simple crystals
well if you're going to try to solve any
real problem in the real world
that could be a really handy tool too so
i don't think it was a bad investment
i think it clearly worked well for
soviet union
you